pendant ce temps je vous le disais la
contestation se poursuit et c'est
notamment cristallisée aujourd'hui
autour des lycées alors que les épreuves
anticipées du baccalauréat ont débuté
des enseignants en grève ont refusé
d'assurer la surveillance de l'examen et
qui a tout de même pu se tenir en tout
cas au lycée Grandmont à Tours une
cinquantaine de manifestants étaient
rassemblés les la Turquie
bac trop tôt retraite trop tard les
revendications se mêlent dans un slogan
scandé par une cinquantaine
d'enseignants grévistes venus de tout le
département pour eux il n'y aura pas de
surveillance des premières épreuves du
bac on pense que c'est bien trop tôt
jusqu'à présent les élèves avaient une
année complète pour préparer ses
épreuves et là on leur a un peu de leur
préparation de deux bons mois et on
trouve que c'est que c'est un juste pour
eux et très anxieux car c'est la
première année que les épreuves de
spécialité se déroulent en mars
conséquence de la réforme des lycées
discutés depuis 2018 des examens du Bac
plutôt donc une difficulté à boucler le
programme en temps et en heure à cela
s'ajoutent qu'une matière peut être
évaluée sur deux jours différents pour
des élèves d'une même spécialité en
mathématiques par exemple donc il y aura
un sujet le lundi un sujet le mardi qui
donc par définition ne seront pas les
mêmes et donc qui peuvent poser un souci
d'équité au niveau des élèves l'idéal
c'est que le bac soit va compacté en
juin avec des épreuves nationales et que
ça pose pas de souci de disparité au
niveau des élèves une greffe de la
surveillance qui pose parfois
conséquence pour les lycéens c'est un
vrai cas de conscience pour tous les
enseignants savoir mais qu'est-ce qu'on
fait si on se met en grève aujourd'hui
on pénalise nos élèves sauf que ça fait
trop longtemps qu'on compte sur la
culpabilisation des enseignants pour que
tout se passe toujours bien donc là
aujourd'hui bah tant pis soit on
convoquera des candidats à une date
ultérieure soit on prendra des
rencontres des notes de contrôle continu
ça c'est déjà fait il y a pas de raison
que ça soit insolu bilan des courses les
élèves ont finalement bien pu plancher
ce lundi après-midi la surveillance a
été assurée non sans mal par le
personnel du lycée Grandmont